ils ont cassé le projecteur portes et
serrures forcées dans cet atelier
municipal les stigmates du cambriolage
sont encore visibles
les faits remontent à la nuit de lundi
dernier le maire de souci est averti
chez lui par la larme installé sur ce
site il ya peu venu très vite sur place
ils constatent des mouvements suspects
autour du bâtiment et décide alors de se
poster à l'entrée avec son véhicule
la suite l'élu la raconte lui-même un
moment j'aperçus des phares donc j'ai
tout de suite compris qu'il voulait
prendre la fuite
donc je suis intervenu avec mon véhicule
je me suis posté en face ils ont essayé
de l'éviter et j'ai réussi à les prendre
par lé par le côté à pousser le véhicule
dans le fossé pour les immobiliser sept
autres élus venus lui aussi sur place
blocs alors avec son véhicule la voiture
des deux cambrioleurs qui réussiront
quand même à s'enfuir à travers champs
mais laisseront leur butin sur place qu
tailleu et tondeuses
en tout plus de 5000 euros de matériel
tout neuf d'entretien de jardin c'est la
deuxième fois en quelques mois que la
tour des municipales cacher dans les
bois et cambriolé en décembre dernier ce
sont près de 20000 euros de matériel qui
ont été volés la délinquance s'écarte un
peu des villes qui sont de plus en plus
sécurisé et c'est vrai que dans les
petites communes de bon par rapport aux
moyens on a on n'a pas la possibilité de
sécuriser de la même façon nos ateliers
nos hangars sont un petit peu à l'écart
des habitations donc ce qui permet aux
voleurs d'être tranquille selon les élus
le matériel serait ensuite revendu sans
grande difficulté sur internet ou des
vide greniers en région parisienne la
gendarmerie a ouvert une enquête
le véhicule qui a servi au cambriolage
été volé et immatriculée en
seine-et-marne les temps qui courent
expertise de même que le matériel
municipal retrouver